[Music]
in 3 2
action so good good good
[Music]
good you love bad name anyone but him I
didn't approve him you know that you are
literally the last person on Earth I
want to see slap the out of you I
really could and I'm open to that in a
safer
[Music]
environment you been a ghost no phone
call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so how have you
been God I hate that thumbs up stunky
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunk guy
we need to keep it super profes profess
is my middle name he said your middle
name was
danger how do we do
boss really yeah holster that it's
Holsted it's done forget you you never
saw
it Tom
Ryder the biggest action star on the
planet is missing you need to bring him
back B J's movie is dead why me you're a
stump man nobody's going to notice you
that's your job no offense I'm mean some
taken you find Ryder save Jody's film
you get the love of your life back I'm
not the hero I'm just a double not today
you're
not Tom we only need you back on set
pal oh
dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail he
was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I had no choice I had to do some
Jason boor
they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you making
you you can't make it it's too dangerous
got me
stairs
what happened to your face you look
terrible you look
amazing you fall down you get right back
up how far would you go for the one that
you
love I'll BL you drink when this is over
engage your
core yeah
boy what you doing later want to go to a
beach somewhere drink a spicy Margarita
make some bad decisions yes
oh the heart and you're
[Applause]
[Music]
to cor under
tender
[Music]
foreign
go minus one
Heroes that's something the world sorely
needs
Avengers I
am
[Music]
inevitable there will always be
more finished my
work this is just the
[Music]
beginning she's destroying every place I
call
home and taking powers from
this if I don't fix this it will be the
end of everything you got
this I'm
asking for one last
fight
[Music]
the Marvel swe PG-13 in theaters
November 10th get tickets
now so I look up at the stars to guide
me and throw caution to every warning
sign I wish I wish I'm sure there will
be challenges that find me but I can
take them on one at a
time so I make this
[Music]
wish are you ready Rosas who is ready to
have their wish
rented I read your heart's desire you
are their handsomest most beloved
sorcerer King you're right I am a
handsome
king last night I made a wish on a star
what are you five and the star
answered ho ho
there I'm talking I am talking who knew
my voice would be this
low King magnifico has the wishes in the
castle he'll never give them back the
power we have to free the wishes and
return them to the people I have a plan
Not Us Then Who
when don't fight
he
not what we know
now what we know now from one
domesticated animal to another help
us so I make this
wish you have something more for
us I make this a wish to have something
more for
us
this Disney's wish we PG only in Peters
November 22nd tickets available
now why are you here
Ral I lost my
job the baby's going to be here pretty
soon no
respect what you do with those
feelings you know you could be a part of
our
family
I know some guys they like to help out
guys like us with they're like buddies
ears the doctor wants me to get a bunch
of tests tests are so expensive do you
still want to go through with
it other guys like they live with you
just like regular families except
regular folks don't get to choose their
family we do how would that work depends
on
you why do we make ourselves so much
smaller than we
are
pain that holds us back take back your
power
Ralph welcome Ralph son manad
drum what if I'm just
broken you have to raise an hard me
inside
yourself baby you really got to tell me
what's going on
here
watch out for yourself
okay there is no God but
r
what you decide will be the only thing
there
[Music]
is when I
sleep I see strange
[Music]
things
memories not Memories
new
things I see
everything that is
not
[Music]
everything
what a wonderful
day did you have family in the for sir
yeah my father missing an action over
Germany so you followed him into the
force yeah I did you're sure about this
you You' only just got your night rating
it's a straight run across the North Sea
perfect night for flying everything
seems to have stacked up in your favor
looks like you're going home for
Christmas thank you
[Music]
sir so charlie delta emergency calling
all channels come in multiple instrument
failures electrical fail F stat is
critical why W somebody listen to me
please get me out of this bloody
mess what I wanted was to come home to
spend Christmas with
[Music]
you Mr Johnny went out on his last
Patrol Christmas Eve
1943 just 14 years ago
tonight if this is it then I don't seem
to be afraid
anymore used to go out over the North
Sea looking for a crippled plane
sometimes in fog so dense you couldn't
see your hand it's light
[Music]
tonight Lord please send someone to Lead
Me
[Music]
Down
it's
incredible you
live you die it's the in between that
[Applause]
counts I got a proposition for you need
you to take my boat out for a run yeah
okay
pop to I was wondering maybe you needed
an extra deck hand my brother I'm
curious curious about what Charlie about
me about you too
maybe we're going to show you what real
fishermen can do we're going some
Canadian
Waters what happens if you get caught I
got a
new getting caught is not an
option Canadian Coast
Guard your vessel's been
seized if I got a $100,000 fine I'm
going to lose my father's boat now over
I never should have trusted you I do not
understand the way you're built you
built me
a I can't help you you're going to have
to do just what I ask you
to I like my resources you want to do
business well Maybel here said you guys
are one timeing but if this works out
this is it one time
[Music]
only do you know what line you're
crossing right now
I she set us
[Music]
up you
live you
[Music]
die it's the in between that
counts do it is
over Professor L yes and a ah nice to
meet you and you good
luck Dr fre sit please not there that's
the transformation couch you'd be
careful why would you come here to see
me if you disagree so passionately with
my views you've insisted all your lives
that the very concept of God is
ludicrous yes clash between God and
Satan ah but I did not say whose side I
was on I consider what people tell me
far less interesting than what they
choose not to tell me have you
frightened off your professor yet not
yet soon
perhaps you challenge my disbelief is
that great I do well done God to late to
stand back
now it seems to me Professor you've
never matured enough to face the terror
of being alone in the
dark what is it you think I'm so yeah
we're all
terrified do you bury your doubts you
bury your members of the war but at the
core of your
being we're all cowards before
death look at this place anemone the sun
is shining everybody's out there having
fun makes you want to get out there enjy
them doesn't it well I'll see
[Applause]
you now do not forget you are the help
they are the guests your sprit has aride
CL of you got to get out of your shell
buddy come on Army I'm not like these
other crabs all right I don't throw my
claws in the
air I don't wave them like I just don't
care W wakey this is for your own good
but what
you ask go to Dan what you got mov girl
what did you say to me what no no no no
no no that wasn't me that was uh him him
who me me me oh he's so
cute hey look
out aren where are you aren how far are
we from the ocean in bles I don't know
maybe a million this may be the furthest
away from my mother I've ever been wooo
it feels amazing girl have you lost your
mind oh this my
jam How You Like Me
Now are you you know lost and afraid for
my life other than that can't complain
come on open your eyes now I liked it
better when they were shut what are you
doing kid oh foren
[Music]
[Applause]
it is good to see you out of the
house what do you think they'll think of
us oh
snap are you finished yet c crab cuz
you're standing in not drinking
water de
Edith you foxy ass old
carry on
you really are a trixy old
and you're a sad stinky in
the end I think it's just
jealousy I think we know who it is love
my neighbor and I tried but I'll get you
in the balls that she's heinous Edith I
didn't do it I believe you may be
charging an innocent a woman police
officer oh look flowing Pig I've got a
daughter at home why would I risk it all
you you want in the nose holes
you old beetle beetle
right if you meddle in my case these
will be on your
wrists in prison Rose may find some
Kindred Spirits in prison no no not the
murders or the rapists I'm thinking more
the drunks and the queers maybe just
trying to find a bright
side he you D all slippery old
Dodger why would I send a letter when I
can just say it
I probably say that you look like
Queen Victoria shoved a
netop or I don't know you
stick come and and the C you make
look like they fall out some sh
better I have a
plan will catch them in the
ACT what would your husband think my
husband is in a li so he's not thinking
a great
deal I like her Rose I ha
her you don't like the idea of me living
this house do you I'm going to lose her
we're not standing for it I had one now
everyone is going to
know it's
[Music]
German there's a young
man I talk to him I wish I was SP
[Music]
you that's really weird
Lisa I'm the
[Music]
greatest Taffy says it's a waste of time
to try and fix a way it's better just
accept a guy fls
that's so
[Music]
cute I can't do that not until we bury
the
[Music]
body
Sav and in the next life there remember
me remember
[Music]
me really hope this goth phase in
soon
mahito
so you made
it mother have a
seat it's this way
mahito a lot of strange things happen in
this place Jo us I just hope he stays
safe save me save me my what exactly are
you your mother she's awaiting your
rescue I'll be your
guide what is this
place this world is filled with the
dead I know it's a lot but I have to
see I'm looking for
someone let's
go we must protect this world ourselves
go back now Michel
Michel you and I aren't then's or Allies
kid don't let go no matter what
[Music]
ready you see this
world there's more work to be
[Music]
done
a gray Heron once told me that all gray
herand are liars so is that the truth or
a lie a lie
truth we have to be alive
[Music]
too well hello baby girl how are you
today so good it's Christmas Eve oh yeah
that your child loves Christmas just
have fun christmase Christmas Dad isn't
that nice sound like wounded
ducks and what was
that do you mind telling me what you're
doing in my chimney can you see me
what's your name my name is Nicholas
Santa
Claus what is this those the carrots the
M said I need to eat healthier so she
think this will Wing me off the cookies
has worked so far if you're really Santa
tell me what Charlotte wants for
Christmas she wants a pretend makeup kit
and scooter he's right see Dad I've
never met an 8-year-old girl that did
not want to pretend make upet
man who are they it looks like a a
snowman an elf and a nutcracker AKA
every Tuesday at my house got a dash oh
no what is going on those bad guys are
acting my naughty and Nic list but I got
some Associates here Eddie's a non
believer really oh claustrophobic I'm
sorry what claustrophobic fear of Santa
Claus that's
ludicrous I get it you don't believe but
I have to deliver Christmas gifts
tonight Dad we need to help him where
are you guys we're at Santa Claus and he
has glitter and there's these people and
they aren't actually El bring my child
home why you still have a white beard I
died it if I want to look younger I
deserve that how can these two out Fox
us out run us all I want to do is I have
you start believing
again what you about to witness is a
sleigh being pulled by eight beautiful
reindeer this Miss PIR the
Bluetooth who do you work for some
people think I work for mother nature or
father time recently everybody thinks I
work for Beyonce but no every married
man would understand this I work for Mrs
[Music]
Claus buckle up The New Adventures of AD
and de starts
now oh sorry uh The New Adventures of
Adam Dex starts
now you think I can get a job at Good
Burger I'm putting a good word you Mr
Jin that's not Soap by the way it's
maple syrup
why do you guys serve veggie burgers I
can serve anything on the
menu are you using a plunger to unclock
the shake machine as in the same plunger
we Ed to unclock the toilet uh no it
really means a lot that you came to see
me well you're my best
friend we're going to be opening Mega
good burgers in cities all over the
world from Hollywood to Hong Kong Hong
Kong is not a city it's a name of an
eight King Kong the game with the
paddles ping pong the sound a doorbell
makes ding dong what we shut down this
store shut it down shut it down I don't
think you really understand you're all
fire I like that fire fire it's hot you
just got
hustled welcome to MBG can I take your
order wa Mega Corp wants to replace
everybody with robots we got to do
something they're going to change the
world here's your
f
[Music]
I ask for no ice but there's ice in here
ah no problem
dud I'll get you another
[Music]
[Applause]
one on the
E that's it oh dude I'm glad you're
back
[Music]
[Applause]
d
[Music]
a